from screen junkies studio in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
booty fight now your host Andy signor
hello screen junkies and welcome to
aloud episode of movie fight so excited
because today is a viewers Choice
episode that's right
this episode has three fighters that you
the viewers at a home about it for let's
get straight to a muqam to your guys you
voted for Mike Carlson colleague Andrew
and John Roca are back here now here
does work and I'll go through your
interest in a second I'll explain this
is this this uh there you go Mike get
this first again this is not this shows
going to work this is a important one
because the winner of this show will
come back in two weeks to take on the
man on the fact-checking couch almost
they're going to come back the winner
here will come back to take on JT and
Scott Matz who already earned something
to that table ganja with a metamer so
next week's fight will feature not next
week two weeks next week we're doing a
DC fight all DC topics will be great the
week after that will be the finals
championship finals which will feature
GTE Scott mance and the winner of this
chair now the winner of that battle goes
on to take the champ on one on one and
an epic championship the belt is on the
line
fight Dan how you feeling I'm great my
bones are really loud at kitware
javanese chapada super loud I'm great
it's been a long time that's much better
thank you it's been your local writer
tonight - so long sigh week-to-week who
knows
yeah the selectors have been able to
fight for the belt and I love fighting
for the belt I want to fight it about
more I want to fight one of these guys
for the belt if they should advance or
if it's jte or it's a man whoever it is
I'm ready to fight ready to scrap all
right well now you're super soft man fun
killer anything no you did I love the
hair okay how's it good accessibility
good all right all right
well I'm excited to see how this goes if
you guys are watching live hashtag movie
fights live on Twitter dan will be
chiming in but let's talk about today's
fight it's going to be worst movie and
the Alien franchise you guys are going
to pitch a venom solo movie and you're
going to tell me what is the worst movie
poster and the most unwatchable movie
some fun stuff today
let's meet our fighters once again these
through you guys chose first up get that
hashtag mechanicus ready
it's my Carlson wired up baby here I'm
back I'm thankful to be a fans choice
that means a lot to me yeah
and I'm wearing my normal clothes
yeah he did he came right in from the
elevator on that koi the master of the
speed round welcome back sir
Stan's thank you I I really wanted to be
here so the fact that I am I just I this
is the most honed I've felt so thank you
for giving this chair this is your
second chance at that it's a there you
we we opened up the floodgates who even
lets people who lost the last show to
come back because we thought this is the
fans choice it's their call not ours
you're back how you feel how you feel
mr. you learn mm no I did I also learned
from the marble fight and I now know to
keep an eye on the cross ride I yeah
yeah content so I'm ready from all
angles all right thanks aim and now look
who's back it's the outlaw himself mr.
John Roca forever Savage babydoll
forever 7 we gonna make it happen up
here I wear no cub cub Scout outfit I
wear changement trying to imitate
anybody the outlaws here the fans voted
for the outlaw and the outlaw is here to
take the belt eventually from Denver I
think it happened what a lot of us
outlaws the fans did vote you here
genuinely very my congratulations but
man there's some people are so mad
you're here yeah I know that's right you
have you have you have that persona now
it's love or hate the outlaws don't
we're gonna learn either way they love
it or they hate it right man well that's
not a lot in between with you no no I
don't like it that way yeah I like I
know where I stand always yeah yeah yeah
that's why you wanted and I love it but
hey I'm glad you're back and it's going
to be a passionate show excited for
having thank you all for coming back
let's do this you know how this works
I don't need to explain the show to you
let's get to it hear the music what a
lovely night why you decide
don't fight verily a good job do to love
it getting used to it round 1 now all
these questions are fans submitted
sometimes we sneak we don't get to sneak
in as you want this week we went all in
so in honor of the fans voting you in we
want to make sure we delivered what the
fans asked for and this one comes in
from Brian Knight at project a project
Avant he wants to know what is the worst
movie of the Alien franchise Mike
Carlton you're first alright
alien and aliens are beloved movies
everyone everyone loves them I don't
want to use love too much but that's how
much we love these movies ok they set up
a character we love they set up a
universe that's amazing a tone they obey
that's an iconic terrifying villain
species of aliens and then the second
movie you know it builds on that aliens
and it makes it bigger we're talking
it's a military thing and the action is
bigger and it's more exciting and it
creates these characters that we love
like Newt and and by the end of that
Ripley the second movie Ripley has
overcome so much ok she's like a total
she's a character that is just like a
the ultimate badass alright and how does
alien 3 build on all of that it doesn't
it lets us down it opens up by killing
off all the characters we like off
screen in a fire and you're like what we
let those were a carrot what happened
does it a cool it didn't even do
something cool it's not even like an
alien attack the ship or anything it's
like they just died in a fire and now
she said this is a dreary sequel this
thing doesn't this just like deflates
everything that's been built up it is
unmemorable it is unexcited alien 3 is
the worst of the Alien franchise hmm
alright coy the only thing worse than
being unmemorable and unexcited is being
disrespectful and shameful and just the
worst thing and man alien 4 is just it
not only doesn't do anything what it
does do is bad and aggressive
the movie not only sets us up to believe
that we have a clone of Sigourney Weaver
that shows her merits by playing
basketball
she then moves forward with acid blood
and is suddenly like a sec sub Sigourney
Weaver was meant to be the heroine we
always wanted and they made two movies
where she was perfect I think she needed
and she actually said in this movie and
I quote who do I need to [ __ ] to get off
this ship how do we end up with a movie
written by Joss Whedon where a woman
says something like that who was the
greatest heroine of all time
alien 4 was worse than what happens to a
toad to get struck by lightning this
movie had an alien-human hype I have to
rebuttal after cuz there's too much I
can't even think of all the bad nail
'i'm for its that aggressively insulting
well john roca I hope you can't go
you're gonna need it for the fight let's
get some real straight yeah alien 3 not
great aliens for not great but when you
bring back the original creator of the
1979 alien the one that got us all
loving what Cub Scout was saying that
the one that got us all into it right
you bring it back and he shits the bed
completely with something called
Prometheus so terrible from the
beginning we get this weird kind of
thing there's all about a white dude
thrown stuff in the ocean and what we
never even come back to it we everything
to the engineer shows up what's the deal
with the engineer oh he was just a pilot
that's it that was it that's all you
waited you waited 30 years there there
was just a pilot it was so ridiculous
because the expectations were higher
when you have a new director when you
have a french director you're not
expecting much but when you got the
original guy coming back and all he does
is fill it with crappy dialogue that
Lindelof wrote for God's sakes we know
him present everything give the mystery
don't give any answers and then some and
then cast incredible actors like you
just Alba and Charlize thrown a Noomi
Rapace and give them absolutely nothing
to do and make the run but even is even
more jury than alien 3 because all the
scientists all the people in the ship
are incredibly moody and bitter and
frustrated even though they found
exactly what they've been looking for
for four years so it's an incredibly
this is a critic terrible movie animate
alien covenant a slave to it by having
to play with it having to
the mythology they brought up and tried
to address and really just you just
broke your heart that the guy who
started the 1979 wood alien completely
almost destroyed his franchise with
prometheus
all right guys wound up I feel like
alien 3 I had enough merit in the fact
that it tried something different and I
feel like I really that didn't really
have tension in these films was mine
because of the style he made it almost
slapstick nihilism it has tension
there's there's a certain nested native
country that was assembling he was
figuring out what he was doing and I
feel like Prometheus was enough of its
own animal that it doesn't really become
an alien film until the third act so
it's really hard to for me to judge it
as an alien film because it was like a
1979 director stepped away and when he
reimbursed he was older in his opinion
wiser right and then he made a thing
that was the vision he had the studio at
11:04 where as alien 4 was trying to
recover from the abortion that alien 3
was that killed everyone and then alien
4 had an exponent had only things that
were the subject of the nineties like
nothing feels more a piece of its time
than the mess that was this Ron Perlman
is barely walkable in it like there's a
bunch of actors similar ears I just
can't do their part because the writing
is so bad and then the CGI its overlaid
it takes away all the things that alien
works it distracts from the action
because it's just a weak piece of the
series all right that's where the three
is redeemable in its way because it's
Fincher it was his first time directing
feature you see shades of what Fincher
is going to do in films coming up
afterwards you see the stuff going on
they took a chance they put it on pedo
comedy they made it smaller they give
Charles has done Charles dancing on mr.
Levite Oh grandpa Lannister's up in
there rolling through there so you got
all this stuff going on any of the
iconic shot of the alien right in
Sigourney Weaver's face that everyone
remembers actually waved her head she's
got all this stuff going on and being
you have a zero Morse and you just look
at the extended the deleted things
almost even longer it's even bigger it's
it's building upon the mythology of it
and it make and the tension it's
actually there are some great themes in
increase that have fantastic tension now
aliens 480 and 4 yes some bad stuff but
it's a European version of an alien film
so if you're a European film watcher you
get a lot of as you know is trying to do
because if you seen city of lost
children he's laying the groundwork for
what he does with sci-fi his version of
sci-fi it's more about
the connection between the characters
it's more about the journey in the
mission of what they're trying to go
through and they want to play with this
idea of how Sigourney Weaver's character
of Ripley is connected in way that in a
way that's almost primal with the is
alien xenomorph the creature itself
therefore they stride that nailin 3 when
it bursts out of her stomach and she
fell all the way into the fire but then
in four they made her a clone and they
made her have a child alien so this
whole thing is her life is so connected
to the alien that every piece of our
humanity is always connected to this
xenomorph up until the end to where she
lets her own child die and that's one of
those memorable moments when you hear
that sound of the child dying is amazing
whereas whereas Prometheus you come in
with more expectations and you were left
out it's come if you go over a bump you
feel your balls drop you are a bump you
go over a different and higher when you
fall off a cliff that's what happened in
Prometheus you're falling off a cliff
because you expected to go sky-high and
that play an exploitable manner and
crashed in the other the only reason
aliens 3 is anywhere a lien 3 is that
even good is cause of Fincher I mean
this is notoriously a movie that had
like tons of rewrites and tons of
problems from the studio and you can
feel it because it's so like weird and
uneven and like these are two movies
though that are trying to do something
different my movies trying to be the
finish of a trilogy these are this alien
Fork not a great movie by the way but is
trying to do sort of more of a schlocky
90s monster movie I mean it is weird I
don't love it but there's tons of more
memorable stuff I mean Perlman is
watchable he's always watch it will
never say he's not much fun during a
whiter Trump there but they always want
to press level 7 and prometheus is a
good movie I love Prometheus this is a
movie about exploring and looking for
God and then when you find God he goes I
have no answers for you I will kill you
I love it it's amazing I think people
misunderstand what this movie is all
about I love it I think that I agree
these are all three different types of
films and I think what he did was he
came back as an old director or made an
art house film my film was slapstick
which is the opposite word alien
represents alien one was about the
horrors of darkness and not knowing
what's happening alien 2 was escalation
like you said in action alien 3 was
nihilism alien 4 was what was alien for
it doesn't even have a tone it doesn't
matter paces on a heartbeat that movie
just happens at you and insults the
other three before
and it doesn't really allow anything but
for me because after akima had to have a
hard reset the previous was better for
it
look what you're saying you just called
it an arthouse film so you know what it
is you can't say you don't know what it
is you just said what it I don't have
failures no you said you just said four
was Nordhaus film I think you said it
was slapstick and then you said about
plastic but it's not observing you know
what it is but it's not slapping there's
no Three Stooges going on in Alien four
there's nothing that there's a chest
burster used in the back of the head as
a punch-out joke and point someone
bursts out wet since winter chestburster
is communica leaf that's embarrassing
that's a curly a little bit of comedy
with the tension that's always ever
happens in all the Ilya Weaver wasn't
even in for media so the expectation
woman for an alien film where that was
called it aliens : Prometheus like an
alien : Covenant was the Covenant had to
do is repair the damage from for
Prometheus had already set and fixed I
think permeabilities no no it was
recovering the damage from from
prometheus and so it means so much so
that they give it they introduce another
version of David which is Michael and
all that goes on in alien covenant is
trying to become I mean he made a movie
to apologize for Prometheus that tells
you how bad it is no one made a movie to
apologize for three or four that way you
went regular apologize well there was
right well it's because they went too
far with you know this this is more the
stakes are higher the expectations are
higher your stepdads going to use you
but when your dad abuses you it really
hurts
that's what I'm trying to tell you
that's how it works you stick that abuse
it hurts but when your real father
abused assume there's more level suit
and you can take these two you can't say
these two films are different in this is
this is this is the completely different
film it's up it's on a penal colony
they've never done that before so they
talk about why I'm watching these are
again movies where the start of new
franchises I mean Ripley is not the same
character and for this is this was
supposed to be another series of movies
and it says prometheus is so these are
different movies starting a new
franchise might the third one is trying
to wrap the whole thing up and just fail
spectacularly like imagine Return of the
Jedi and it starts with Leia being like
Oh Han died in the Carbonite and you're
like wait what yeah Hannes is dead like
Jake Jake came back it was like oh we
cloned everyone and then they're gonna
have alien babies it's the same thing I
don't love it
but if it was like oh look oh and by the
way Chewbacca is actually the son of Han
Solo like it doesn't work in any way to
have this man I agree okay but now have
you're having to original and drive to
come back and have all these incredible
plot holes like people here just lost
when he can't he has the map on his arm
and he gets lost how the hell did that
happen how do you let that go is your
director white up there not always liar
it why did David spike Holloway's drink
if David didn't have emotions what's
that all about why did they pretend that
whaling was dead the whole time and then
he shows up and we see that whole thing
with Charlize thrown coming like an hour
before it actually happens there are so
many plot holes and missteps you get
easier sell those terrible French accent
whatever the hell he's trying to do you
get em m8 and then when the ship is
falling on top of Rapace and Tehran you
know what they do instead of running in
another direction any other direction
they run straight backwards in a
straight line so the thing could roll
them over it's all it's akin to what you
saw in Austin Powers
when Michael McDonald is 40 feet away
from the bulldozers are going no and
it's slowly coming it's so ridiculous
that the man who did alien and Blade
Runner could create a film this
incredibly terrible with so many plot
holes I mean how did Sean I feel immense
about of excruciating pain as she's
jumping around [ __ ] after she's had
a c-section with that thing that came
out of her which apparently made it with
the with the engineer and then created a
proto Cena morph that they already had
paintings on the wall they did not even
created the proto see no more I had a
friend who had his appendix out and he
was at a party the next night saying so
they're saying a few sort of appendix is
an abortion as I returned remember your
birthday very strong no I was not I'm
did I really don't know exactly where
the xenomorph is is that living and
actually the uterine walls we don't know
exactly where that is
it could be just dating anywhere in the
body they didn't explain in the stomach
it's alright let's not make somewhere I
agree I want to go through final
thoughts and it's tell me again why
yours is the worst movie in the
franchise over the other two back to you
Mike okay as I have stated before this
thing just bungles it this this like
drops the ball at the touchdown line
they're the only memorable thing in the
whole thing is that shot with Sigourney
Weaver shaved head with the alien that's
the only thing I remembered about it I
had to rewatch it I was so bored I
rewatched for and I said oh this is a
piece of crap too but there are a lot of
fun weird stupid things in this it's a
schlocky b-movie and much more memorable
mention it makes it better
Prometheus sure there's some
they don't they don't pick up by the end
of the movie but this is a movie that's
not trying to be a lien it's trying to
be its own different thing and I liked
it I liked the theme that explored and I
thought it was did a great job of doing
that quite I think mine is the weakest
because when I think of alien 3 I think
of Charles s Dutton I think of that
iconic scene I think of a lot of David
Fincher shaping who is director and I
think he's the best director working and
it started with a Liam for anyone
investor activity on there and I think
that Prometheus intentionally stepped
away and had to rebrand themselves and
knew what it was and knowing what you
are as a filmic is whatever she should
do I feel like of you three the only one
that doesn't know what it is is my film
the movie has slapstick elegance as
attempts at whor it has attempts in
pension building the movie never defines
itself and then not only does that
insults the character reverb for three
movies then three cousin work of
observing Weaver
mine makes the word Weaver a punchline
and then has your say punchlines and
then makes the aiming of the punchline
and it actually is disrespectful I'd
have something be better to be not
memorable like you're claiming three is
then be memorably bad and insulting and
alien four hurts to think about okay so
Prometheus for me about alien three I
think is a good film I watch it I own it
I have that film that's a good for a lot
of good tense filled scenes fantastic
work brothers character actors so to me
I think that film is absolutely
redeemable I think four has some great
stuff if you're a fan of arthouse French
films you understand what you know is
trying to do with this franchise once
again see city of Washington with
Prometheus the problem is that really
comes back to like you said coy comes
back to as an old director he tries to
do something tries to restart this
mythology this franchise and he fails
miserably none of you have talked about
the plot holes in your films there are
my just mentioned four of them there are
massive plot holes in prometheus that
take away from the overall effect of
what you're trying to accomplish and it
has it has done one thing by releasing
that film and really start putting a
stamp on it
it in fact it has now infected the
entire franchise going forward because
they have to deal with all the stuff
which you saw an alien covenant and I
get in and you see at the end of alien
coming it they're going to deal with it
again in the next film so all these
terrible mythology all these things that
they introduced in Prometheus are just
going to poison the rest of the trilogy
that they're creating much so that they
will constantly be a
and exponentially more disappointing and
terrible as we go for it and it's
because Prometheus is so horrible all
around
all right on my bail me but get my bail
behind me but ding Dan what I think a
discover fact checks the new version of
David is Walter emotional covenant not
Michael there's a lot of folks wondering
if alien vs. predator was eligible for
this contest that was a lot of what
early on I forgot about a lot of
restrooms and that would've been a great
day a lot of dance a lot of people
everyone oh we always do but broke I
think he said that the sug an Austin
Powers was hit by a bulldozer oh the
steamroller a roller and I found a quote
from Joss Whedon regarding aliens for
people that were surprised he was
interviewed a while after he said it was
mostly a matter of doing everything
wrong they said the lines mostly but
they said them wrong and they cast it
wrong and they designed it wrong and
they scored it wrong they did everything
wrong that they could possibly do so
just weed not a fan of alien for but did
say he was a fan of alien versus
Predator so okay there you go
for that go that's why we knew exactly
as far as everything else goes up pretty
clean round so clean oh yeah I can't ask
Dan for advice on this because that
would be a little bit shady for this
show I don't know what the appearance of
want right sorry alright so based on
these arguments this is legitimately
tough because they all fall three of
them have bad definitely things going
for against them the cannot be the thing
I keep hearing about three as well well
it's good because it sets up venture I
don't know if I believe that the defense
on for its Ashlock EB movie and then
Prometheus shits the bed because Ridley
Scott took over an alien 3 but I feel
like I heard more I didn't hear his by
didn't hear more negative things against
3 so I think it's 3 is safe so we have
the most positive things and then
therefore they did sort of get you
because it is it while you're watching
Fincher it is there you do remember that
scene that's seen in the
tension that films so I gotta cut it
Mike out so Mike sounds between Coley
and John and then it became previous
verses resurrection and your arguments
it's tough because Prometheus does have
something but I'm trying to go through
my notes
alien force schlocky and you're you
really hung me out I forgot she had that
line who I have to have to give him this
[ __ ] to get off the ship that was really
aggressive for me Thea is filled with
pot plot holes but it's still a kind of
a beautiful film which coin shinned man
this was rough I gotta give I just have
more points from John Owen that he made
so I'm going to give John the first
point alright thank you
I don't agree with it but I are sleeping
that is based on those arguments it was
a strong a strong fight and I heard some
more attacks against them
sorry that was kind of possible in my
head ever gonna say I'm an idiot and
don't know how to judge but know that
made sense to me
and going through it John give me the
most attacks against the two films and I
feel like they did sort of get alien 3
on its iconic imagery and four is kind
of a sake silly a fun movie weird movie
or maybe it's really did come back with
expectations that did not deliver
according to these arguments and I would
agree personally alright here we go
round two
dan was the fan say well in fans the fan
poll has a clear winner 55% shows alien
four and the worst movie 26% voted for
Prometheus 19% aliens creep alright
uphill battle for me look in the low
Fincher alien vs predator probably one
yep yeah that one all right here we go
number two this one comes from Garret
McDowell at Gary McDowell one on Twitter
he wants you guys to pitch a venom movie
the solo film for venom what do we want
to see coy your first smartphone opens
with Tom Hardy working out and stressed
and drained and there's just years of
anguish in this man he's a beast of a
human but he's broke
behind them are walls covered in
newspaper reports accolades this man is
a star reporter what's wrong with him we
then follow him through New York and he
goes to the church now any spider-man
fan knows how important this church is
he goes of the church and he is going to
kill himself this is how this man ends
and we don't know why right before he
does he pulls out a newspaper and we see
Sin Eater we see all of these classic
Easter eggs from the comics we see
backstory told their newspaper fittingly
The Daily Bugle which gives us more and
we find out that Eddie Brock is a
scratch reporter because of spider-man
and because of Peter Parker and we find
out that he's been disgraced through
lying about this report he's about to
kill himself when the venom Samiha drips
down and then he's overcome with
emotions and feelings and sights from
space and he's suddenly invaded and then
this movie goes full psychological
thriller and we discover what it means
to be a man what it means to lose
everything what it means to be an alien
how to feel like an outsider and that's
the whole second act is discovery and
emotions and feelings and no dance
numbers and then the third act is the
evolution of him taking control and
redemption and the redemption of the
first act basically him finding himself
again and him shaping into the lethal
protector and the beautiful thing about
venom is he always thinks he's right
then always does a choice that he
believes is right so in killing people
he kills bad people but he's doing it
for justice we have that partial flavor
where you love this guy and it's not
Hardy so he's charming and he's dark and
he's doing these horrible things but
you've had two acts of grilling to love
him so when he kills fever like I agree
with this and it becomes a horror movie
for the audience you as the audience
feel horrible about the action this
person is taking you've fallen for that
you believe in because of the perfect
casting and the beautiful thing about
setting it up with the church the
beginning is spider-man's not in this
film that's what they've said anytime we
have spider-man in pictures we have
spider-man in newspapers we have the
Shroud of spider-man that keeps us in to
yours
in the universe but then in spider-man
like five or six when whenever Tom
Holland catches up to the right age it
can end at the church and we can
retroactively Lee have this being the
spider-man black comic saga because
movies don't have time frames movies
don't have chronology that needs to be
that way this is a movie set after
spider-man Tom Holland is old enough to
play the right black spider-man and we
can earn venom
cardamon spider-verse retro actively and
it's tidy them hmm
John Wow that's good you leave out
Secret Wars I have to yeah you have to
right okay to me I go totally sci-fi I
see you make Eddie an astronaut and you
play it like classic old-school
1979 alien which we just talked about
here in our previous fight with Ridley
Scott you make it so that the symbiotic
is hunting them they don't know what it
is right they don't know where it's
going in or what's gonna what it does it
imitates each other you got a little the
thing vibe going on there from 1982 or
81 the Scott Mansell kill me and at the
end
Eddie chooses between saving the others
on the ship like his best friend or a
love interest or saving himself by
bonding with the symbiote that's the
twist to the whole thing Eddie is
leading them getting them out to doing
whatever he needs to do to survive even
slowly becomes the leader because he's
not initially the captain Eddie Brock is
kind of a kind of a lone cat at times
kind of meathead as we've seen in the
comics at times so you can play that way
so he slowly becomes like the leader of
this thing and at the end it's him it's
between him and his love interest and at
the end he chooses to bond with the
symbiote and we see that we don't see
the twist coming and when he does were
like what and when he chooses that he
becomes the villain that we need to set
up for him for the sequel when
spider-man shows up Mike Carlson okay if
I'm Sony I want to differentiate these
movies from the spider-man movie so I
want to make them very different and I'm
going to take my inspiration from a
comic book series of called venom which
was by Rick Remender a few years ago
venom is not Eddie Brock he is Flash
Thompson and he's a war hero he lost his
legs in combat and the US military
enlists him to take part in a special
program because they have the symbiote
so they essentially have figured out a
way to effuse a guy with a symbiote for
an hour and he becomes of enemy it's all
the crazy cool venom powers but he
cannot stay in the symbiote for more
than an hour or it will overtake him so
now venom becomes an agent of the US
government and he goes on missions so
now you take him out of New York because
look we've seen like we have six movies
people swinging around New York we don't
need to see that right now Sony wants
something probably too that will set up
so they have a hero somebody that's a
probably the linchpin of the universe
because it's bizarre they're doing all
these spider-man movies without
spider-man and they're just going to
like do all these characters so you want
to lease the new hero
Flash Thompson is a military hero he's a
good guy obviously he's going to have
darkness he's gonna have struggle
because of what he's been through in the
symbiote but this is going allow him to
go to places like in the first movie
whatever we can't call - Savage Land I
think Sony probably doesn't have Savage
Land but what's called like the jungle
land okay he goes after you know the
Miller jungle jungle habitat any of all
the 70s rock songs we could go to and
you can go after you know a villain like
Kraven the hunter you know and then he
can go on a mission and now he sort of
becomes the new spider-man but you take
them all these different locales and
it's a very exciting thing it opens up a
franchise it's not just one interesting
movie now you can actually take vitamin
all these different adventures and it
opens up the possibilities all right
find out I feel like all of these are
our franchises yeah like all of these
set out the universe is so Nene does the
two problems I have here are the the
movie with yours doesn't have a there's
not enough characters for us to have all
the Easter eggs that comic fans want it
doesn't have a story that's a narrative
from the comics like the space thing was
jonah Jameson son so everyone be like no
like John Jameson summons but always not
an any Brock's an astronaut he's a dumb
Plunket flash Thompson's earning the
neck spider-man movie and he's been a
movie fight fighter like so we can't
have a character introduced again
because he's in them film he goes to
high school Peter so if you're trying to
make a shared universe you can't have a
high school student and then suddenly is
Tom Hardy it doesn't work we can just
call him any bra so the problem would be
the comic fans of love would hear on
assembly Flash Thompson yeah okay they
won't get a problem is those things are
already intrinsically a problem going
forward the universe because of how much
people love venom now my film as an arc
is the venom story it's the todd
mcfarlane flavor and at the end of mine
you have a fully formed venom with a
full arc and he's accepted easily the
protector you haven't fightin you
haven't go to jail you have the
redemption saga and then at the end the
post-credits scene is already set up he
gets out of jail and there's that piece
of venom left and up carnage second
movie it's a franchise it's ready
venom is like a shellacking 90s
character and like I want to see him
done fun yes
knighting dumbness he's night I mean
that's bad as Carnage's that's the
ultimate yeah he's not like cable I'm
just studying like you're villains there
I'm trying here what is income make
shriek man I like chouriço cabbie Gawker
like me I do long shot I don't know why
I'm tired what I do I'm just saying this
psychological it sounds like us he only
kill himself this is depressive isn't
depressed a lot of people in the theater
like I think you want something that
actually lol fine Logan was really a
rough sell right come on no I don't know
I mean I wouldn't say Logan either
because that was built up from other
movies or so you had that going for what
I was done I'm right it was but you're
you're what you're setting up here is
you're just you're playing for a
franchise right you're trying but you
still got to focus on making it insular
movie just in case so you've got to be
able to walk that line because the last
thing fans one is like oh crap I'm a
damn good film you didn't answer any
questions
fine relation right spider-man 2 so you
don't want that going forward so with
with you with your guy with Flash
Thompson a lot of people remember I
someone's being a jerk to Peter Parker
so are you going to play you said you
want to start him off as a hero but what
kind of hero are you going to create
Eevee such a jerk to Peter Parker is
what we've seen that's what you remember
from that from the women series maybe
you'll most of the time he's the jurist
if you're is a competition for Mary Jane
all that kind of stuff right and the guy
if you want to go with a guy with the
warrior that's Joe Jenna Jameson son
that's that's where you want to go so
with flash time you messing up with the
mythology when you're doing that we saw
that early BBS really doesn't work we
try to cram three graphic novels in one
damn well that and navigate through
lines we can get a mind character
honestly change his name it doesn't
really mean it's like we're not College
it's called spider-man better are we
Theo shakes out well that would be weird
I agree but we just need a guy who lost
his legs who's the war hero
damn they can't bend dance so you're
talking kappa hores go went on things
they use update some people's names out
and they make them sort of good and bad
and they change things all the time as
far as the case far as the alien movies
but it does sound like alien that movie
sounds like alien or that movie that
everyone thought was a venom origin
movie the camera lens sound exactly like
I'm not saying that's not going to be
good it's just like we've seen this a
lot and also it's called venom like we
know he's going to be vented by the end
of the movie like that's sort of the
whole surprising right oh my god e's
venom so by the principle that
everyone's gonna be not surprised so I'm
looking for something we're like we're
usually you're going to see things
you've never seen before you're never
seeing the venom right a dinosaur in a
Savage Land situation you've never seen
him go up against
kazar or Kraven the hunter or you you
want to see you want to do something
different with these because we've seen
everything we've seen so many of these
types of movies before I want to see
visuals I want to see settings I want to
see adventures that I've never seen fair
but I want to defend my movie a little
bit here I think he's a space kook none
of you have talked about how he's going
to come to existence like and my movie
addresses that my movie the
dissimulation thing that it's they go
into some kind of maybe could be solar
flares could be an asteroid suit could
be devistating something on a planet
thing goes inside then we start the
process because that's what I would be a
partner in secret Wars it bonded to
himself in secret Wars on that planet
gave him all this powerful stuff and so
what it does with Eddie is he will
occasionally like the thing is bonding
to him so and then you know I flex it
off whatever but as he gets more more
connected to it he starts to feel
smarter stronger faster more virile all
these things that he wasn't before and
it progresses to the point where you can
start to feel something for him and it
becomes an antihero for what he does and
maybe love interest lives and becomes
carnage maybe his best friend lives that
he chooses and becomes carnage so you
set that all up for the franchise
already and when they crash land back on
earth who knows what happens from there
so to me that's that's why I think this
works better because it addresses the
fact that it is a space alien symbiote
that come because all you all say and he
just shows up and - it makes logical
sense that he would show up when he
shows up I just imagined your final
thoughts kind of coin I plan has an
origin because he gets set up in the
movies that they frame it around so you
can have the actual authentic origin
with spider
and the way Marvel's doing is cosmic if
Sony left spider-man borrow I mean sorry
let someone borrow spider-man again
that's where they're going to keep going
to space in a vendor store this can all
happen the right way my way win by not
having a by having a mystery in the
opening of the film not only is that
more interesting we also allow for the
proper space introduction without
muddling the film people that know that
absord will be excited people that don't
have been George it will be excited it
works in every way in the entire second
act my film allows for that growing of
zero and all those feelings and mine is
a movie that's unlike any HBO movie
because we not dealt with the drug abuse
feeling of a film like this is literally
like he's got a psychological attachment
to this thing like a bad relationship
and drug abuse this is like everything
we want in the pathos is a character by
Tom Hardy a man that can play it you
look at Bronson you look at the take you
look at how this man commands and
performance and then you add that to the
fact that we have a character that
literally could be one note handled
incorrectly we have military movies we
have those things I don't need to see
that I'm riding a dinosaur reason for
them I want a movie where I know what I
care about the character if I'm gonna
have a shared universe starting with
this character I need to care about him
psychologically and this allows for that
aspect of venom that is so under it in
the comics and can be played at home are
you will like I think we all want to see
venom running a dinosaur a second of all
look this is I'm talking about all the
fun stuff and the neat things I think
with my movie too though that is a real
if returning it psychological yeah
you're going to get psychological of a
guy who can't walk a guy who served his
country a guy who was lost who
sacrificed everything and now he has
another chance to walk he isn't and now
not a just walk like goo walk like with
his gluey legs and stuff like this is
like you can you can delve into the
actual psychological aspects of venom
because that is part of it but in
addition to that in my movie you were
getting a scenario where he can go
anywhere do anything you can go in a
space you can go into different settings
I think that this thing is exciting and
it can take it anywhere whereas I think
the other two are limiting hmm
dan any that up just a couple of venom
from the age of enemas it immerses
apparently experiment number 300 in may
yeah Korea Roca you mentioned Blade
Runner so I will correct you as Scott
mance as this question John said the
thing at least on June 25th 1982 is the
same day
and the greatest film ever made Ridley
Scott's Blade Runner save weekend I
would Philadelphia as I would tell me
that I shall die I sawed into a clock at
the cedar on 3rd and Denver my [ __ ]
the meals I remember ah long it's got me
back I'll be back in a couple weeks
anything else no that's it I can't
really correct there a picture and you
do the rest of the show again man
all right based on I mean I'm still hung
up on how great that movie life would
have been if it was venomous hand I
would have been glad what's hot yeah I
want to cut you out I don't know if it
works out having an amazing like sort of
Cloverfield a stingray ending what and
then Jake Gyllenhaal cat venom yeah oh
man hold almost fighter man I don't know
anyway I bet something but that's not
what you pitched so I didn't like yours
because I just thought in life so it
came down between coy and Mike yeah I
just
while I agree you can just change the
name you sort of got stuck in that
problem so I think quois is a little bit
more presentable so I got to get point
of pointers admit they were all dead
[ __ ] kitchen I love Tom Cruise's yeah
it was a great - thanks alright round or
the pole say the pole was oh it's tough
to summarize these pitches in the hole
but uh 42 percent voted for venom aka
Punisher and 39 percent voted for
Cynthia covenant mmm which was not
John's yeah I think hey one cohered one
the third with splash status land venom
says 19 percent sure okay I like venom
Punisher venom punished Netflix has been
implied later together I don't any
having to you could end up being shamed
everyone I'm happy I could try yeah okay
should have probably entitled right
screw round three
this one comes in from cartoon Palooza
Joey che Joey T cartoon pas improve any
movie by adding captain yang Merrill
here we go as a fifth it's pirates movie
came out or it's coming out this weekend
it came out and I'm out
yeah it's coming out to a boil a
dinosaur or if you're watching this I
hate to be I will not judge Aventine it
but a lot I feel like I've seen it
already I've seen it and I'll tell you
right now it's out and you could go see
it I mean you can you could also stay
watch I guess no good no god I know it's
so did the point everybody and I went to
the premiere of Miami and I had to like
riding on using like the Spears
yeah I love her that you're on me too
man I saw he tried resort Goodman right
they all the cast was fine mattress
actually so badly directed and written I
don't know what I wanted to be
anyway happened yeah I'm sorry yeah it
was not a very it was a bummer like I
wanted to I want to just go and have
some fun and they watch fight watch like
this anyway mess I glad they watch or
pirates but we are talking about one
pirate in particular I'd like you to
improve moves by adding Captain Jack
Sparrow John Roca your first ladies
gentlemen I will tell you what the
answer is and we we shouldn't even fight
it just give me the point because it is
the 1992 masterpiece starring Martin
Short Mary Kay place and an older
crustle
captain Ron alright john-boy this
amazing that if you read you know this
musical what's so great about this
what's so great about having Jack
Sparrow take the place of what basically
would take the place of curly they made
her wear a bikini and like photoshopped
her to fit in that right yeah no no not
it was I qualify hydrogen times we need
a bikini girl like holding her what does
that biggest margin abortion
is Charlie please anyway that poster
without China
yeah real Captain Ron Popeil spider-man
homecoming poses anyway no but anyways
like what what to me if you replace Kurt
Russell with Johnny Depp then you have
this whole like you replacing not that
not together so you adding he was yeah
okay improve movie by and I said you
could replace okay so what they do no no
I'm fine with adding what they do is
cross old stumbles into that someone
island where the guerrillas are and
there is Captain Jack Sparrow why
because they wanted traverse the
Caribbean that is what they say in the
movie they even say Pirates of Caribbean
a couple of times and we Martin Short
does so we know what they're doing
they're going to get this this yacht
from their other debt his dead uncle to
turn it into money it's Clark Gable and
Carole Lombards yacht so they know it's
going to make money if there's anything
Jack Sparrow knows it's how to find
treasure and how to make that treasure
pay for him plus he likes to ogle the
young girl so the daughters therefore
that way they should the shots of him
the car also used in that video camera
very inappropriately in 1992 to to take
shots of Martin Shores daughters but I
don't understand what's going on there
but Jack Sparrow could be there don't do
that that's not really cool you do it's
not like an internal body or things in
on the barrel but it does exactly how to
do it
and that's the thing the movie doesn't
quite hit all the funny marks it's not
as good as you would like it to be with
someone like Martin Short and Kurt
Russell in the movie so what you need
you need someone to bump it up you need
someone to bring the comedy bring the
humour bring the action bring the fun
and I think with Jack Sparrow he be very
be incredibly incredible at bringing
Islam and making it so much more
enjoyable for film to watch plus he's a
Seafarer already so where Kurt Russell
is limited in his ability to train them
he actually would train them in a way
that's more playful and fun and exciting
and you could pump up the score that
stuff out in the ocean the stuff with
the gorillas you can see Hans Zimmer
scoring it in such an incredible way so
already the film is a thousand percent
better by adding Jack Sparrow because
there are so many more options that are
open to you so many more playful
adventures that you can have so much
more you could even make the film to a
half hours long which shouldn't happen
for a comedy but you could do that with
someone like Jack Sparrow because that's
certainly the the pace that they go to
with all these Pirates of the Caribbean
movies alright captain Ron the Caribbean
Mike Carlin a riddle these notes them
yes rebuttal
too many all right here we go I picked
Disney's Lone Ranger all right
yes Rangers first of all how would you
not want that look at that like I don't
eat the writer barcoding perfect baby
bring the bell I get the point
sure dams - Minnie all right here look
Lone Ranger me look to people kind of
like this movie me and film director
Quentin Tarantino that's just you know
he's a genius I'm a little bit of a
genius that's whatever but you know love
the internship with Robert De Niro which
was actually solloway adorable yeah it
is adorable at a better than the Green
Zone the Audrey it's great help intern
um so look Lone Ranger is like two and a
half hours it's on it's on it's own a
little long but some good action
sequences some interesting stuff I would
argue the first Pirates of the Caribbean
you take Captain Jack out it's okay it's
got some decent action but like it's not
a special Captain Jack is a big part of
it now if you take a Johnny Depp
performance like Captain Jack that is
beloved and you put it in a
two-and-a-half-hour movie that's a
little long but that's some good action
sequences we're talking dynamite baby
this thing is going to soar all right
now he could probably also just get rid
of Tonto in the first couple minutes -
and just join The Lone Ranger side and
then we won't have to have the problem
with Johnny Depp playing a Native
American guy and I think that's actually
an improvement as well so I think that
he's absolutely going to improve this
movie ten times a hundred times in time
in fact oh wow hundred I didn't hear
that from John a hundred time ago
hundred times coin go ahead and prove
movie a thousand times that's a chump
argument family 101 now a boomy that
needs improvement that could have been
really special that thought it was
really special that had a budget that
was really special it is Waterworld
well now this is a movie we're in a
Kevin Costner I mean if that isn't a
moster I don't know what is now Kevin
Costner thought he was making Mad Max he
really did and he tried so hard but
imagine if in sailing and peeing off
boats and drinking it and all of the
madness that happens in this film he
stumbles into an actually interesting
character Jack Sparrow now Jack Sparrow
is a supporting character she has best
when he's a supporting character the
biggest Flavel that franchise made was
making him the lead
I bring it back in being and supporting
Karen many but that's a big one
in making him the supporting character
with Kevin Costner dealing with the fact
that not only is he trying to solve the
world problems than Mia curmudgeonly old
man he's now going to deal with a
drunken pirate Johnny Depp could add the
humor back into the franchise he can add
some lightness to a movie that was just
drove for no reason Kevin Costner buddy
making Mad Max and he wasn't if there
was a light-hearted flavor with a pirate
of the Caribbean while they go look for
dirt together imagine
Captain Jack talking about looking for
dirt as a positive thing how much fun
that would be
Disney could have had a big hit with
Pirates of the Waterworld pirates of the
Waterworld Lone Ranger Jack Sparrow and
Captain wrong in the Caribbean here we
go find out alright you can't do pirates
of the world because you're combining
two different movie parks franchises
that would never work they would never
allow you to do that to start off with
that's just number one right to exit
Universal for Disney that's not good
there's no way they're going marbles are
you just me I work for University no
effing way to record Roger Rabbit yeah
90s spider-man not out yeah well there
we go
and with what we got going on here you
thing is there's no pressure for him but
this is a movie exactly that's not
enough for to make it exciting for
Sparrow so he's almost wasted in the
movie like this doesn't necessarily make
it better because you're not improving
the plot in any way the problem of
Waterworld is the plot it's the plot
itself it's not the acting it's not even
a dialogue sometimes it's mostly the
plot it seems useless and wasted and
there's all community sequences won't
cover up as bad as the plot is already a
movie and what you've got here with dude
so your your solution to Lone Ranger
yeah is to eliminate the Native American
character that's what I mean like the
whole point is the half Native American
representation and then which your job
is let's whitewash them and then let's
eliminate him that doesn't make any
essence sense and then slide in Johnny
Depp as if he's going to replace Johnny
like this it makes no sense that you
piss off the audience even more you piss
off the people of minority people even
more you piss off the audience even more
if I don't something like that because
you don't get rid of the boring part of
it which is army hammer in that movie
and you ask someone you should replace
it isn't replacing Tonto with with
Sparrow and it's based on a show like
that's so sacral you have to have like a
beloved character than be to Johnny
Depp's for
little bit like a first act and
instantly one goes we had eight Johnny
Depp's and pirates three didn't work out
so well right so we don't need to add
another pirate pirate situation I think
the thing that Johnny would be searching
for with the dirt would be the fact that
he assumes there's more there and if
we're in a world where there is nothing
the thing that it ain't worth more than
rum is dirt right so like the humour for
me is the fact that Johnny Depp would be
not seeking out these crazy things is
that he's looking for dirt because
that's the most idle saying the plot of
Waterworld I agree with the problem
because it did have beautiful production
design and had a great cast example but
when you add the humor of someone
looking for dirt and make that a comedy
punchline it changes the total somebody
that's a logline Captain Jack Sparrow
goes looking for dirt sound good to
anyone else because it doesn't matter
I've some good anyone but yeah that
matter does Lone Ranger with Emily
there's a long way after Jack's birthday
let's see okay it makes sense it doesn't
nail in what universe its brother
Bahrain I wanted to talk about the
captain Ron catch real quick we're
talking about the word masterpiece was
thrown around the world around so it was
yours
oh yeah but that's already two and a
half hours we can captain Ron and an
extra hour long has been saying first of
all captain runners already like a less
good Jack Sparrow it's like you got to
Jack Sparrow's and also go you have a
better jack a big part of your pitch was
that they were going to both be pervy
towards your girl that was a big part of
that look any not sound good and not see
that there was a girl even see how pervy
he was procured Knightley was literally
twenty years of junior when everyone
would be captain my daughter is much
younger than Keira Knightley my king
she's getting married in the movie have
you seen this money you cannot years ago
haven't seen it Cub Scout come on now
movie fights I've argued plenty of
movies have never seen it myself next
home oh these movies are true Jack
Sparrow's why is that how does that
benefit the world and I'm the only one
that doesn't have another character is
similar because there's nothing more
different than Kevin Costner Jack's
better that's the funny but both of you
are trying to show Cummings into dramas
that makes no sense you just we just
talked about Baywatch bullying started
it's like that's the problem rain water
comedy rhyming into a drama and yet what
lonely just like an action-adventure
alright so it's when his brother gets
killed that's not a drama in the most
vicious by Maddie it's your budding
heart a con man
traumatic it is tremendously key what do
we do with more burgers or more parity
regs I don't need more Verbinski needs
to experimental time
the thing is captain ones already a
common so it's about improving the film
you improve the film by making the film
funnier
you don't necessarily make it longer I
was a joke about that but you could make
the film funnier you make the film
better you have a good cast already
Martin Short the problem Catalan was
Martin Short was was cast as a serious
guy now with Johnny Depp he has a chance
to play be more playful with someone
because because Kouros is not
necessarily a comedian naturally John a
Johnny Depp plays this very funny
always the jack to Captain Jack Sparrow
so human Martin Short were to have more
banter that would be funnier would take
more advantage of him mary-kate place is
a fantastic character action sheet of
rolled with him too with the little
flirty stuff all of that would have been
there so to me Captain Jack Sparrow just
increases the value of the comedy of
that film and that's what the question
was which film is better is better not
on it is increased in quality by adding
Jack Sparrow and I think Captain Juan
absolutely is using that his final final
thoughts me yeah Oh first of all I just
wanted to say Waterworld you come to
Jack Sparrow it's like a different movie
there are not only a lot of fun antics
and what's not going to make any sense
it's it's a totally different totall
thing sure maybe Captain Ron is a
comedic and Netta would fit better but
but Waterworld especially like do you do
like well what's the scene where Johnny
Depp is I feel like Keith Richards
doesn't make any sense
all right Lone Ranger there are a lot of
Native Americans in it and what I
probably didn't say is that Tonto comes
back in the second by a Native American
I didn't know that might go that's the
thing I guess I forgot it we get heated
in this stuff but they don't say it's
like wait okay I'm just saying that we
what between if we're talking math we're
just talking like gore verbinski two and
a half hours some good action sequences
plus Jack Sparrow equals good that's a
math problem and I think that it always
ends up with the same answer a very good
movie call a laptop two and a half hours
gore verbinski pirate movie is pirates
one we have it it doesn't need to happen
again and your argument is that mind
would be totally off Lone Ranger is a
drama action adventure movie there are
similar genres I'm saying Lone Ranger
and Captain Ron are decent films
Waterworld is not a decent sentence it
wasn't
which is going to be the most logical
insertion of Jack Sparrow it was which
is going to improve the movie the most
mind goes from an S that literally
almost sank an entire universe I mean an
entire network studio there is word
he'll sing an entire studio these movies
didn't affect cinema so direly that we
look at it like a giant wart on the face
of mankind this would improve a film
because it started as an acid my code
would be any movies are ok and it
doesn't work for the same reasons and
Lone Ranger because it is a totally [ __ ]
but it makes it better
alright Dan Quentin Tarantino did name
The Lone Ranger is one of his favorites
of 2013 along with other movies
including before midnight gravity
kick-ass 2 and this is the end so unique
is always some taste John you were half
right about Captain Ron yes his daughter
is getting married but she's 16 years
old
there you go Lynn Kevin oh wait a minute
she's 19
John Cage is getting married on Who am I
gonna believe you or the many many
sources on the internet degree I mention
get married at 16 own it makes no sense
inside legal in any state nothing I can
register it is yeah but is he legally
married his cousin what you look certain
yeah without what I passed along I mean
I will depend I guess when the Caribbean
the you can nineteen though I have found
multiple sources that say that you're
wrong so give them my number I like
water
seems like news big news where do I want
explain anything else and in the
Caribbean
uh no no other than that bad alright
yeah
two and a half hours I'm captain housing
I'm joking you didn't obese in your look
good telling better yeah what else think
so well you don't know will get any
change of tune and that's so hung up on
is killing off Tonto which was away
question I dealings of her healing kind
of Christmas shagging John's point them
it has like is this a pro is you right I
it was a very good argument there and
then Waterworld yeah I liked Waterworld
yeah I like to see so I was like because
yellow urine was like it's 92 Phillip
that he's a film I mean I know a lot of
people like wire world so it I need a
little bit more you did give it a good
point dogs there were
pirates in that pirate the movie in
which no one liked and then Lone Ranger
yeah I mean you did a lot of math there
yeah Conn captain Ron is the less good
saying and I loved some points for John
where that it starts to pervy dude yeah
yeah I think look I think the math
problem is probably the best point out
of all of them it's oddly Waterworld is
kind of a fun movie he how is going to
go chase dirt and I don't really want to
watch to pervy guys so it might get the
point
oh it's always the extra stuff you save
it [ __ ] you mad their idea was the
Phantom time to bring get the head of
this fan poll said that 54% shows
Waterworld 33% shows Lone Ranger and 13%
shows captain Ron how to clean
everything alright who won that round by
the way I'm sorry
nice my kind of room or online yeah so
much I was going listen we could all do
some here he'll hand you the picture
okay alright this one comes in from been
Abram and Abram a wit sorry
does not say your name I said you'll see
on screen he wants to know what is the
most unwatchable movie of all times
this is a tough one you got to pick some
unwatchable alright cool you're up first
actually why don't just give me the
movies so I weakened or in times two we
all know where I'm good you're picking
Jack and Jill Jack and Jill okay John
bat members Robin who I love these or
game and a lot and rather Batman broken
I miss about yeah my disaster movie ring
you know coupon right you oh sure it's a
bit tight at all alright we're back to
you coin only second although it looks
like this what happens
Michael what Oh
Oh trick question Scottie's of guys we
want to know what is the most
rewatchable movie of all time
oh cool you're from now again you got to
sell this that's what I'm looking this
is a pure debate you have to tell me why
Jack and Jill Rob or Robin Robin or
disaster movie is the most rewatchable
thank you a lot guys you got to fight
for this hard alright boy why is Chuck
and Jill the most rewatchable film of
these three happy gilmore Big Daddy
let it down son Little Nicky well
nothing compared to you cinematic
brilliance that is Jack and Jill now
Adam Sandler came back in a big way
playing multiple roles that should have
gotten him an Oscar the man played
awesome self both male and female show
me a quality of man and woman that is
the fro overarching nature of this film
it shows that both men and women should
be seen as equal and even played by the
same man and a miraculous turn he left
for a little while
happy Madison came back in a big limo
with Adam Sandler not only is this film
so good that it brought in such titans
of acting as Al Pacino and Johnny Depp
ended it with pizzazz that has you
laughing and rolling in your seats
this movie is insightful it's non-stop
laughs it's got cameos it reminds you
what you felt like in the 90s when you
watched a good comedy and it reminds you
that fart joke can go on for 10 minutes
and be the best thing ever
Jack and Jill should be in the Museum of
film should be watched later by aliens
so they know what we represented as a
species and what our men and women were
like together and Adam Sandler should
represent us it's that good Wow
okay John why we're Batman and Robin
more rewatchable let's talk about
something what's the what's one guy who
is untouchable
what's one guy who can't who we love
always no matter he's in shitty films or
great films
he's our governor maybe our presidents
they change that amendment Arnold
Schwarzenegger
now when you litter your film with
esteemed actors like kill bills uma
Thurman good night good luck
sentence George Clooney Chris O'Donnell
kickin it in CSI and then you give us a
female super heroine like that girl
coming in Alicia Silverstone fresh off
the success of clueless this is an
amazing cast and you add to it Joel
Schumacher is unique view of gossip
you've got yourself an amazingly
rewatchable film the style of the film
is fantastic the cinematography is great
the set dressing the visual images all
of it is fantastic keeps you going
Arnold Schwarzenegger is one-liners are
hilarious they're brilliant mr. freeze
has never been more interesting or
likable as an antihero than he is in
this film and uma Thurman is never more
gorgeous and beautiful and powerful as a
villainous as she is in poison ivy you
juices this is just a masterclass in
acting of what you're watching
throughout the whole dough and a master
class in directing from Joel Schumacher
because he is taking on an action ride
you don't even mind the nipples you
don't even mind the back credit card
that's so awesome
we haven't seen that a bad credit card
what a brilliant thing to think about
who would've thought that he's so
fantastic and he's wrapping up the
Batman quad Rolla G once and were always
the best person to ever dawn the Batman
outfit best actor rather George Clooney
what a phenomenal performance he gives
here he gives him new ops he gives him
yes dare I say it gravitas would you say
the best Batman I would say the best for
this argument for this fight yes but
that's Batman ever seen in the history
of mankind
yes George Clooney he's so powerful
Chris O'Donnell is in fantastic shape
that's one of the greatest asses I've
ever seen in latex all of that is so
amazing and plus the storyline this is
him we get the drama of mr. freeze and
his wife like this powerful stuff you're
being moved by the death of his wife all
of that is happening while Batman is
trying to teach Robin to not be an
impertinent fool get himself in trouble
than you have Robin with his
relationship with with Batgirl and she's
standing on her own and her relation
with Alfred we give humanity to Alfred
as well he's more than just a butler he
is he is related to Batgirl they have a
connection to have a love all of that is
just so amazing at least to a fantastic
climates where everybody learns a lesson
and you walk away going I can't wait
till Schumacher makes the next one I
can't wait to see George Clooney as
Batman again Mike disaster movie why is
it more most more watchable mineral
look when you have a franchisor Phyllis
can remove a franchisor films it is very
hard to keep it fresh okay
and your two filmmakers that start out
and you have a dream you want to keep
something going it's almost unbelievable
to have it by you know six seven eight
nine films in four it's still to be
incredible and this is what these
gentlemen have done they started with
scary movie and they made it all the way
to disaster movie I mean we remember
other movies like epic movie meet the
Spartan and also in 2008 I mean how many
directors writers are even making two
movies in one year alone Woody Allen on
occasion but I mean that's about it
other than that is just a scary movie
guys disaster movie is a cast of mostly
unknowns they come from out of nowhere
and we're blown away by the versatility
what they can do and what different
movies they can send up in unique and
funny hilarious ways now look I'm a fan
of comedy but I don't like a lot of this
highbrow comedy I don't like these
Netflix company I like simple I like
bass I like Blue Collar Comedy I like I
like a working man kind of thing I like
guys falling down I like farting I think
a lot of people out there agree with me
the falling down and farting is funny
that's what you're going to get in this
movie disaster movie now you might think
disaster movie oh it's all going to just
be parroting you know movies where
something goes wrong something like in a
hole but bus goes off the freeway or
something ah no you're incorrect we're
going to dis parroting everything super
bad it's parodying Iron Man Kung Fu
Panda it doesn't even have a very
specific thing it's parroting that's
what's so brilliant about this movie is
because the parodies move from one movie
to another hopping genres how do they
hold this whole thing together I don't
know how are they going to take
something like Kung Fu Panda one minute
then parody super bad the next it's
unbelievable to watch
it's like Cloud Atlas but they pulled it
off
that is what disaster movie is this is
an amazing movie i watch it once or
twice a week
disaster movie 2008 Wow all right guys I
had the Pinal we tried we missed or each
other's movies is that I am what's wrong
for God's sakes you came in Hank you
look at me as an herbal essence what is
the worst ever it's like make a gun
raped airplane and had a movie that's
what a disaster movie is it's one of the
worst comedies ever seen there's not a
funny moment to kind of absolutely
chuckle at it at any scene in there and
Athena are located by a car there's a
scene where some guy gets hit by and you
may have four reactors mmm you can't
even any actors no because they blend
seamlessly as hard as they're boring as
[ __ ] not for a Carmen Electra who is a
sexy wrestling battle in it
okay that's fair subject was real
watchability now not only does mine have
the drama of a brother and sister
reunited with the passes of Al Pacino
struggling as a man who doesn't know if
you want to do a Dunkin Donuts
commercial this man doesn't know if his
integrity is so strong he wants to
Duncan noted to be a corporate shill but
he also loves Adam Sandler and drag
which shows the Equality of men and
women there's nothing more important in
today's age than showing that a woman's
looks are everything and even Al Pacino
can love you when you look like Adam
Sandler that's possible her gas problems
are real-life problem her constant need
to impress his real Adam Sandler isn't
blood related to this woman and you
can't stand her every single one of us
can identify with that I know that
family things are real I know that
beauty is only skin-deep in some
people's eyes these movies don't teach
of lessons when you watch my film
laughs you feel you have drama very
watchable because not only is it
community but it's also one of the best
dramas of our time it's not a drama and
P it all makes kill everything anyone
who could possibly kill Al Pacino's
career that almost killed al pacino's
career that's going to be table and you
know what you know what Adam sailing
needs to do be in drag you know why
because there are too many roles for
women in movies absolutely there are too
many roles from winning comedies
definitely play a bunch of definitely do
what Eddie had already done definitely
with Martin Lawrence and already done
I'm doing terribly and then have a
little Indian kid just to make sure
anybody gets mad at you
like what are you talking about Lee it
was such a terrible movie talking
back-to-front fluid or believable
persona back home she barely speak
fantastic an amine oxide aside about and
just kind of stuff she does but you
can't take your eyes off I'm sure
amazing the biggest guy who plays a
skinny God mister for no you're not
going at all and it's the worst of the
Batman citizen even following all the
way to install comics and secure choice
right I think Jack and Jill wasn't based
on source material cuz it transcended
the medium of filmmaking I think you're
I'm misunderstand what Jackie Joe was by
calling it a drama I think it's a comedy
it's a smell like magnum opus is what is
November and Robin takes the Batman
prompt and elevates it to a whole nother
level it takes it to one it expands the
franchise it pushes the boundaries of
what you can do with the Batman
franchise what you can do with the
Batman character Alfred has emotional
spiritual besides serving a [ __ ]
t everybody so having something all in
their own your time
he's dying a mcgregor syndrome they're
not all he's doing always but that's
pain every saw trade on the leashes and
his handler Adam Sandler coming out was
right over me was like Oh drama I mean
he's like no no no when I can do drama
and comedy I'm gonna play true
characters and I don't know how he
didn't get an Oscar for it was like
being John Malkovich of Adam Sandler it
was so much Jonica get the gags and Jack
and Jill are very sophisticated and they
fly over a lot of people's heads Adam
Sandler shooting for this highbrow New
York latte-sipping audience and I think
it's sort of disgusting he used to be a
man of the people and now he's doing
things that people ask me you had to go
to Harvard to understand some of the
jokes and Jack and Jill there's an
amazing with a Mexican family playing in
the park and he not only identified with
the people in the park as an everyman
but he eats their food and when he eats
their food he becomes very ill but he
doesn't blame these people because he's
a man of the people there's a
grandmother I can only be healed by
eating jalapenos what shows us not only
to most people can't afford jalapenos in
college I think it's insane and he's
even putting something like that in the
film Batman or Robin also you have to
have a degree in architecture to
understand the building not only it's a
series of the areas of thing it is going
to be
not even a sideline my doing more of an
experience you do better every time it's
not really what we want to experience
that we want can't watch it once you're
getting the rocket one same experience
or that bad moving are but you can come
back to it and I have missed a damn
thing and I bet one of the ones good
about it no it's going in and out it's a
bond it's a non narrative structure is
something that we know I'm not there are
down low drama now I think the problem
with this film is that it doesn't have a
through line so the rewash ability is
not there because you never know when
you stopped watching you never known you
start watching this movie is purely
comedic and it's meant to be a drama my
movie is both genres put together with a
brilliant actor playing both worlds with
Al Pacino s everything you need and to
watch it again and again for the comedy
and the drop using as a final song Scott
you have George Clooney at the top of
his game uma Thurman at the top of her
game let's just over at the top at the
peak of her prime as an actress Krystal
Donnell as well coming off the scent of
a woman Phil there's so much happening
in this film that is fantastic
and and and it's enjoyable to watch and
you can and there's camp penis to it and
the campus is fun it's something
different for Batman it brings back the
old Batman from the 60s with Burt Ward
and Adam West
and-and-and-and or the kid it brings all
of that back and makes it so much more
fun and enjoyable and playful and you
get but you get the really hard emotion
because Batman does that Batman can't be
cheesy but then it has those moments
where it really hits you in the heart
praise his wife Alfred dying there's so
much to deal with here with Batman he's
going through so much and who do you
cast you've got a cast someone like
George Clooney to bring the right
gravitas and drama to those parts and
also play the light comedy and train
tests Ward his son in essence Robin to
understand to take over the world to be
a man and that's all the tapping so
there's so many lessons from this movie
and the actions fantastic and the humor
is but it's war Sega at his best with
his comedy with his one-liners that he's
cultivated since the 80s you have OMA
Thurman at her sexiest all this is makes
the film eminently watchable over and
over and over again you could bring your
family bring so you watch the Christmas
watch your Thanksgiving it's just a
great film to share with the family over
and over again great script fantastic
score as well and some very def
direction from a very misunderstood Joel
Schumacher Mike laughs ah we're talking
rewatch ability
and when I think about that it's you're
going to see a movie like this on TV
you're going to see on cable and maybe
you'll see a twenty minutes in maybe
it'll be 40 minutes in if you're going
to see Jack and Euler Batman and Robin
when you come in 30 minutes you're going
to be very confused these are movies
they have incredible plots they're very
dense and you're not going to know
what's going on if disaster movie comes
on you're going to say oh this is a
super bad parody and they're the guys
are taking a duty or something they're
making poop and then you're going to go
oh look at this kung fu panda just
farted and you're going to know exactly
what's going on in the film this is
re-watch ability cable is a big part of
when Yuri watch a movie if it comes if
you come in late you're going to know
what their parenting and you're going to
know what's funny about it is a poop is
a duty is somebody getting hit in the
head okay I just I would recommend if
anybody if anybody wants to have a good
time just go to the Wikipedia page for
disaster movie yeah and read the plot
synopsis because when it's written out
for you it long-form Quirinus b1l redone
say later that day will has a super
duper sweet 16 party at his house
despite being 25 the guests include
Junie dr. Phil will not played by dr.
Phil by the way Will's best friend
Calvin and Anton Chigurh along others
oh my god though it's the 21 years and I
mean the experience the princesses 10th
prince edwin challenge is calvin to a
dance fight for her love but a tornado
appears and Prince Edward escapes Iron
Man Hellboy and the Hulk attempt to
fight it but all are defeated by cows
thrown by this tornado and it goes on
your comparison to Cloud Atlas really so
I mean I located are all great but that
Mike really got me laughing I got to had
the most uphill battle I got to give
Mike that point Hamm disaster movie is
so much personal to me ok I know I made
a very clear than
I had in the water by a really really
rising to be a I known bringing some
facility the simple Blue Collar Comedy
exec and Rick so much so so hard when
people came to me while we're brilliant
but I'd like to know that's another
level there so how do you reward that
Dan what a bit sitting online right no
judgmental I hope people use this in a
context for all of us alright
I got there real guys 72% actually voted
for Batman and Robin 12% for Jack and
Jill and 16% fourth is a surprise there
no all right how to treat that based on
the arguments and that Mike really
brought it there that was that was Rob
that's where being a comedian comes in
yeah for thousands of dollars in problem
all right all right
there we go number five all comes down
to this this side comes from Justin
Reese when I do you have the spider-man
homecoming poster we do this just a new
poster that dropped there's a lot going
on it's so bad what's going on sorry we
love we're excited we're already there
what do you you know I've gotta put a
coating on it yeah looking very smooth
yeah with the purple wolf white and we
got to vomit no not a new spider-man
it's ridiculous you Iron Man swine your
army there's a lot of everyone having I
can't believe this got through and was
like yes that one what happens with your
agents in the room negotiate you guys
elevated anyway in honor of that which
was getting made fun of a lot and we
will be will be making fun of it a lot
more in a flex pay tomorrow 4 p.m. 3
Dickey's news join us live watches
always on Fridays we want to ask what's
the worst movie poster comes from Justin
Reese we're to go to you coy we have
your posters ready so cute when you're
ready but what is the worst movie poster
I remember seeing this poster in
theaters and I remember knowing I would
never see the movie and that is Bangkok
dangerous now this is a poster that
makes so little sense in every possible
facet now is he on fire I don't know is
that hand is certainly not does he have
a black hole in his armpit
presumably doesn't that jacket belongs
Nicolas Cage no at nothing hasn't it
cage had a neck not since the nineties
what is going on in this image that
makes sense absolutely nothing and in
the background is a city maybe an AC
behind glass is he in a phone booth
what's going on with those bullet holes
is he running from something there's
literally so much going on in this
poster that it makes you understand the
movie less the point of a poster is to
tell a story in an image a pictures of
the thousand words and to tell you to go
see the movie all I know about Bangkok
dangerous out of that poster is that
it's about a man with a portal in his
armpit that can dress themselves that
might have a hairpiece that might have
been Nick Cage a few photo shops ago and
it's for some reason in black and white
with boils I want to put the tagline
it's all in the execution yeah poured
out now that's a pun on making a tag
lines and within account to its only
institution is apparently this is a
hitman movie now from that image not
only is there not a gun which is in
every hitman movie he doesn't look like
a hitman all I see when I see it's all
the execution is in making fun of itself
it's all the execution we couldn't even
execute a trailer or a poster for this
film please don't see this movie
starting to go stage all right John Roca
what cost are you pickin listen everyone
knows the worst movie poster ever is
Superman 3 let's take a look at this
thing look at that stupid stupid poster
you have Christopher Reeve who had just
come off Superman 1 and 2 Richard Donner
directed masterpieces and he is carrying
what was you what we used to be one of
the edgiest comics on race and and and
drunk abuse and everything in this
country Richard Pryor coming out of 70s
he is a comedy icon and they're turning
him into an Uncle Tom a step-in Fetchit
it is so terrible and he's carrying him
like it carries a woman a white man
carrying a black man like that because
it can't like it should there's so many
so much about this poster that is
terrible all on its own why is he flying
in the middle of the Grand Canyon for no
reason at all nothing about this poster
makes you want to go see this film at
all it's drawn in a cheesy way he's got
a uncomfortable look on his face like I
don't know what he's like trying to say
with that look it's there's a lot
it's uncomfortable brewing to look at
and it's just pissing away what they had
set up already in this fantastic
franchise with 1 & 2 you come out with
something crappy like this poster and
you go oh no oh no and of course the
film was terrible for was even worse and
it sank the whole franchise and - we had
to get it revived by Zack Snyder with a
Man of Steel and so this this poster
it's like you love Superman you want to
be behind Samuel to see something
powerful and majestic and regal and
Noble and graceful
that's what Superman is he's the best of
us and in this he's a cheesy guy
carrying Richard Pryor screaming doing
what is in essence an Uncle Tom thing
and it's it drives me insane to watch
this to see this poster because it does
take away what was one of the most
edgiest comics in the history of mankind
people still talk about him people still
listen to his homage from the 70s and
know he did fantastic you roll placing
saddles with Mel Brooks for God's sakes
so to see him like screaming all you're
missing is the big eyes if you get the
big eyes then you be I've got you hit
all the buttons they needed from those
racist posters from the 20s and 30s so
to me this this is such a terrible
poster because it does not convey what
you want Superman to convey which is
Grace and ability power they should be
together they should be standing
somewhere together because he's a
computer genius he's a computer genius
in the movie and they break him like a
crybaby little guy holding and screaming
alright that's just why I think it's cuz
Superman can fly and he cannot the
guests were like he's saving it alright
but we'll hear more oh mike mamie's we
say highwayman well I mean yes hi that
depends all the colors beautiful like a
ransom we seen crash back then alright
alright alright alright alright I'm
gonna go with the Avengers clips users
bring it up why look at this poster
Grateful Dead it looks like it's like
color forms it looks like a kid just
posted like put their different stickers
around a spot like and then like the
relation the spatial relationship to
each other is all strange and like
there's clearly an attack and some of
them are very calm and some of them are
not calm and Johnny Junior's just like
his arms
hanging out there clearly that's not his
head and a different head on a different
body this is a poster that should be for
like this is one of the biggest movies
of all time where the most exciting
movies of all time and it looks if you
took away the Marvel and Avengers and
you put like sci-fi the Avengers with an
e on it you would go oh yeah that looks
like that that looks about right and you
replaced all their actors with like the
stars of disaster movie which you can't
make but yeah I can't
so yeah I just it's crazy when you're
looking at this thing that this is the
poster for the book the biggest second
whatever third biggest whatever it is
movie of all time you like and assuming
it's not as you know it's it's I don't
know which is bad it's just so bad and I
think it's especially bad because of
what size of a movie it is for that's
why I think it makes it the worst
all right guys find it out I think
you're absolutely crazy Avengers
fantastic in your argument is that if
you change everything about it it's bad
it's bad yes and it seems that thing and
it SS turning and I'm saying it would
make sense there was a schlocky sci-fi
movie no one would and I go wow look at
this high budget poster first Avengers
is the moment they all come together
yeah the moment they all come together
that is it shows you the logo it shows
you the date drive really with the logo
the Avengers a is the May it shows you a
beautiful third act it makes you see the
actors in character and altering the
character at the time saying and that is
exactly what a comment but once they
become together their Rosings their pod
the beauty of comic book poster is is to
make you feel like you're about to get a
car all that the back like they are in
the movie that would be cool also don't
fight back to back they doing a movie on
followed that with this versioning
they're spitting out my sword that
they're not back to bat show this next
to it like I already Jose Castro image
with three people standing back to them
you can't use you miss the person this
is the only way to show and what do you
need to this shows all the Avengers
dynamically and I think the reason of
the Superman poster work is because in
the seventies and eighties there's a lot
of cameo guest stars from like we had a
we had a Bill Murray comic with him a
Belushi coming at them in the cover
there's a lot of plastic there's a
Muhammad Ali fighting Superman there's a
lot of classic comics that feature an
actor and a comic book character on the
Congress right this to me is an homage
to that with the drawing and the style
they did here I love like the hand-drawn
cover I love it feels classic I love the
Grand Canyon oh the scope of it I love
the flavor this
feels like economic I would pick up and
I would read and I would enjoy and
that's what I wanted the movie to be so
the poster Lexy better than the movie
maybe this makes the movie look good you
look great both absolutely insane this
is not particularly terribly stupid
stupid though right what you said about
Muhammad Ali Mahmoud on is being carried
by surveying is he he's going toe to toe
with him that's the difference
they're turning him into a lesser than
and this is one of the most this one the
greatest comics when was one of the most
powerful edgy comics ever and you're
turning him into a wallet similarly a
damsel in distress that's ridiculous
but that's ridiculous I'm taking a money
thing together because he's going to be
beer and you can be flying alcoholism
but Superman always flies on a poster so
you can't like I don't have to carry him
how are we me that's the thing I've
heard enough to surround you might pick
a kind of a bad Photoshop job but it's
not us excited I have no idea we're
talking about John he's a sort of a
silly comic relief and that's remain
saving him coy your posters ridiculous
coy gets the point
there yeah I mean you can make this race
argue but I think you're just stretching
there as I get in the mood in the movie
sort of the silly guy you can't fly for
sure but how do I get it all in the
politics of it he's a silly goofy
character that's what we're supposed to
think it's an Avengers I mean a weird
choice I thought there'd be more to it
but I just didn't hear I don't awaken
time damn Earl what do you think
I usually cut that early alright but
that means koi you're in the finals
against Mike what John look I know you
always think I'm not trying to screw you
I thought you did a great job and I love
when you play and you were very close
you're still in this now you get to help
decide oh yeah sure help us judge here
where this goes let's do this speed
round we're in it these are all chosen
by the fans yes guys it should be okay
that's good speed round tall fan choice
oh yeah we got some crazy ones here we
go John you'll be helping to take
dictate who goes here so if you have any
if your film mean against one of these
guys you can use it if you want taking
the hood down thank you buddy
based on arguments here we go Dan can't
help only you can all right number one
this one comes from Travis of marble who
would you rather hang out with for a
whole day
Rob Schneider or polish or polish or Rob
Schneider okay Mike you've got Schneider
no I got polish or are you supposed to
sorry Paulie and koi has that's right
Rob all right whenever you're ready Mike
I've done it I worked for him it was my
first job in LA and I was up in his
house and he's a very relaxed mellow
kind of guy I know exactly what I'm
getting he has a nice house he had a
nice girlfriend it made me a sandwich
this is all true I swear to God I can't
really I was off the air and I know what
it's like I know he's a very nice nice
guy yes sure he's the weasel he does all
that stuff but like I got paid on time
there was nothing there's no problem
with it
thanks come on if you need that rush
shiner that always seems like a nice guy
off camera but he also has a versatility
to him where I wouldn't just hear the
one and like the style of speech that
would drive me insane he's actually a
guy that can play other things he's
tried it's just that that's how people
wanted for them I think Rob's out of the
person or outside of the actor of
everything that I would enjoy outside of
the person because I have no no idea
what that guy is me see
got he done good work beyond the work
that we can do because he's got a
versatility to only polish what doesn't
oh there was the speedgame in there all
right Mike ten seconds
I got good anecdotes from him like
Robert can't tell nobody has got a
memorabilia all over the house and it
was really cool walking around and going
like oh he's got a poster sign from
Woody Allen like to Paulie I think it's
a love your work babe and I was like
that's crazy
having my hang out with Rob Schneider I
can't say exactly what's going on but
I've heard nothing about Pauly Shore the
man just about how you had a good time
with the sandwiches and things I loved
it about it but I think Roger I was
probably this guy and I know more about
that experience injured that is kind of
came densely really I don't think
something all right well John it feels
like my kind of woman unfair advantage
yeah what I think coin made a great
point where he spoke about his
experiences rather than the man and I
think he made more about the man and he
even in the speed you could get what he
was trying to get about Rob special I
would vote for corners although this was
very very close until he said what he
said right at the end he did yeah it's
true we talked about the sandwich and
memorabilia and the wood but not very
like an alley I would you rather hang
out with for a whole day
our sandwiches are part of hanging
goodbye see that's raw start was yeah I
was listed I was getting there don't
seem to be sorry because yeah if you're
hanging out with them you're going to be
in a big house seeing all the
memorabilia and it does some pretty
entertaining I just think yeah I click
good point close but I think Mike
finally got a little one up on you
they're close no chance I'm not with Rob
Schneider I'm sorry to mention Missy
shorter you would get to go to the
comments or self do I do I did go to
come so I didn't know I ever did great
they Missy - Oh Mike it's the first
point we're back yo all right good we're
even air it's great here we go this one
comes in from uh hold on to choose okay
this one comes in from the weight start
making sure I have the best ones here
who I'm sorry this is from Milan darling
who is the best robot character in a
movie [ __ ] r2d2 so many that are great
I love our duty dicks thank you like
using a clickbait it's coming up next
tomorrow Friday Wow so I figured this
out the time for serrated blade river
count does does Harrison Ford yep well
he's not just been auditioning yeah that
was a question not only here I mean even
if not given number three here we go oh
yeah the other guard Blade Runner i
picturing them in a backwater robot man
oh one reveal all right that's
interesting age-old debate all right
Mike whenever you ready all right r2d2
he's a robot and when we won't talk
about robot character so we want fun but
we also want expressive and likable r2d2
is able to be funny and likeable and he
doesn't even say a word which is amazing
he's one with the most iconic robot of
all time and as far as c-3po is
concerned he's more annoying r2d2 was
like almost the cool level had it one
that I think everyone would agree is the
more popular choice I think that r2d2
ultimately ends up being more iconic coy
r2d2 is interpretive Lee interesting
c-3po actually has dialogue he has
versatility he feels things he
translates he's the most usable
character so not only interesting and
comedic but he also actually does things
as a translator he has more uses and
he's comedic so with the writing of the
character there's more involved in
there's more investment Amy Lazar you
care about there's actually things going
forward you a moat more to see Tokyo New
York GGG
c-3po is a more annoying character and I
think he's more divisive among people I
think r2d2 is almost universally beloved
and I as far as the arm r2d2 also wakes
up so he does things too he doesn't just
ten seconds
r2d2 is on/off switch doesn't count as
the character development my character
is anarchie actually translate things
without c-3po r2d2 wouldn't get a point
across you need r2d2
with the three POC three videos the core
the linchpin all the duo
[Music]
does he have an ark that's interesting
yeah John what do you think he doesn't
work if you if you stated the fact that
he said in New Hope that he is not a
storyteller and then by Jedi he is
telling stories that would have been
hard to say which would validated your
argument well I feel like he made a
great a better argument to some round
because of the versatility of r2d2
you're right that's why we love them as
much and you too you speak as much about
why we enjoy c-3po so much
I agree might get the second point so
coy you got to get this one here we go
sorry I mean also you spilled oil okay
over the place when he's in that one
scene and look how I didn't think my
vision will haunt me the rest of it
Wally
Kaye to essa/jesus did Artie was like
I'm stuck in our - you are - Ollie was
one of my choices for banning a
terminator right remember okay the robot
by the way uh yeah whatever powers it
for the purposes of the question I think
I get it given the right don't enjoy
daddy
there we go number three this comes from
archway zero what is the best movie
office to work in hmm and you're going
to say does it have to be a traditional
office with like cubicles and stuff they
have it has to be a place of business in
the Avengers Tower sure stuff like that
okay in that case um anchorman oh yeah
alright anchorman vs. Avengers Oh like
this mic here first all right Avengers
tower state-of-the-art as I was saying
before a big part of it is eating
sandwiches Tony Stark attacks is
probably the best sandwiches the best
cooks that's going to be incredible as
far as we're sleeping arrangements he is
the top of the line beds he is like the
Sleep Number bed I'm sure it's whatever
you want it probably has two sides that
are different you can have a woman or a
man sleep next to you and they won't
even feel it if you get into bed it's
going to be incredible it as weapons it
has protection you will you will be safe
there my office features the height of
comedy at all times you've got Paul Rudd
you've got welfare at the height of
their game you've also got crazy hijinks
with news you can always be entertained
and you're going to have the best choice
of seeing the entertainment through the
best versatility that office would be
fun to go to every day and it's always
hijinks and you're not in danger you're
gonna die this office is always trying
to be killed
story there are aliens coming to kill
you mine is safe and funny adjusts
entertaining without thinking to do the
anchorman of us is there going to be
rampant sexual and racist aggravation
it's going to be insane there's going to
be violence you're going to be
constantly there's a woman and a man
fighting all of a sudden and it's going
to be maybe funny but after were you I
would take a woman of some am fighting
over a robot and a giant God from outer
space fighting right as much day for
while still being entertaining still
funny and I get all the news from the
best sort and I'm constantly laughing
and I'm safe and it's important to me to
be safe I'm at the office
Yakko I got the safe thing connected I
confront in the whole Trident and all
that man yeah clarify yeah does the
argument of the man the woman that would
get really doing it a while but still
and I think I got a great job yeah where
I think what office has week number day
I want to go there like ability of
Nathalie things you're still in this koi
he needs to you need to get this one to
win correct yes
I need one more to win yeah okay correct
well he needs to get this to get this to
win right right because it's a game
James right right right all right this
comes from DJ 69 so fine cool cool what
actor should join Arnold and Dane DeVito
in the upcoming triplets movie Dave
Chappelle Chloe grace Moretz coy you're
a first time he's got to take a second
spot set it on in
the buting twins the beautiful imagery
of those named Amedeo and giant Arnold's
first thing you add the triplet and dave
chappelle who is coming back and it's
finally on our return comedy tour you
have comedy in three different aspects
three different flavors of comic all in
one musical baggage and the imagery the
storks difference between Arnold in
DeVito and they smell is the most iconic
poster I can picture I want this triplet
movie because it's funny and somatic and
we need to remember okay these are all
guys they're about the same age that's
not that funny we want somebody with a
40-year age difference okay so Chloe
Grace when she was four years younger
yeah they're going to explain it by the
fact that that when they were both born
there was an egg that was taken on their
mother and it's been incubated for over
40 years now they have to learn that
this is their sister it's insane how are
they going to get along what about
texting Millennials hashtag car they
don't know any of the sub business all
right coy 10 seconds use and wisely what
is the list of great regrets web you
enjoyed winded versus how much you want
day Michelle to come back I want to
movie that I'm already looking forward
to seeing already buffeting for de-spell
are short-sighted and we know that
beautiful number G that kind of comedy
I'm already buying the ticket player I
read some prime chloë grace moretz is in
her prime yes certainly kick asses I'm
last favorite but was the movie Dave
Chappelle half-baked guys we don't even
know that he's a proven actor he's an
amazing stand-up comedian Chloe grace
Moretz says the good she can deliver
comedy and action
oh good I was hoping he would pull up
Sorority arising neighbor's toy yes yes
yes he didn't so we can't do that but he
did bring up kick-ass so he did answer
the question Chappelle is in the private
that I got stuck on Ken Chapelle still
act where your thoughts but also that
way you met your point and I want to
give you the points because you said the
hashtag that all that stuff that brings
comedy gold because those two guys
aren't going to know what that is
she's going to help them go from
adventure to adventure because she's
going to know how to get them in and out
of these situations and it causes comedy
go Glee what is this a tepee you know
there's all kinds of what is it self you
got a poster right right right well I
liked it if Chapelle but you're right
Chappelle's not approve enacted we don't
know what he can do past half-baked
comedy specials have been on even those
two a Netflix ones right up to me I was
with you but then yeah when you had to
hit back of his even until proven
accurate it's a very good point I gotta
give it to Mike that Mike takes the win
congratulations
Wow I did not think that we going to
happen for my Chloe crib oh my Carlton
be back in two weeks to tackle JC in the
booth
oh and got movie man me win that seat
how you feel on Dan about that show and
now you're in your next potential
component because you pick three more
different competitors to potentially
have to fight for the belt that is going
to be I don't know how to approach any
one of those three so what's the sale
the semi-final plays out it's going to
be a foot no matter which one of those
three it is gonna be a fight to the
finish
it sure is and I got to thank you three
for coming out and thank you man's for
voting you because that was a great show
so glad you come back Mike Carlson exFAT
Carlson on Pat Carlson on Twitter
anything else you'd like to put uh yeah
the thing I'm in Netflix I'm in a little
part in Jeff Garlin's handsome on
Netflix see that I'm in a little part in
a show called complicated that just
premiered on a streaming service called
booboo well sounds well Mike's Twitter
Craig Julian former host of clip cup
funny I love ya and cliff cup that that
Craig sooner Craig Kelly has had as a
his started hit he has his own like
dramatic comedy shown out with a 30
minute special like a 30 minutes I don't
know and you should watch it and I'm a
little part in that so it's all my 204 I
mean come on
yeah it's called complicated and it's go
to my Twitter and you'll see it there
thank you very much alright
koi where's like send the folks I you
find me at Co IJ a nd Rea you on Twitter
and Instagram and I was inspired by the
speedram stuff I'm doing like minute
reviews on stuff you guys tell me to
review so basically I'm using the powers
I've honed here in this environment like
comic reviews movie reviews like all the
media we all enjoy but I'm trying to get
a lot out at you in a minute but it's
been really funny guy than receptive so
Instagram you can see those twittering
kudos and you thank you again for
getting back here this was a blast yeah
please come back any time as well John
Roca please come back any time love the
energy pageant outlaw what do you got
brewing
hey you guys got always fly me at the
Roca says on Twitter and on Instagram
every Friday on collider movie talk at
10 a.m. and my new podcast just debuted
four weeks ago outlaw nation we talk
about a whole bunch of stuff that's in
the geek world like we just covered the
Batman with Amy awesome my header as my
guest to drop today we talked about Zack
Snyder leaving just like David Griffin
came on stalked Alien franchise so
whatever your instead of whatever you
like politics sports not just the geek
and nerd stuff not just film and TV not
just video games all kinds of stuff
going on that absolutely I'd love to
have all you guys come on in and talk
and so it's a blast so guys go there and
then there I just closed the deal on new
show that's going to debut in a couple
weeks and I'm really really excited for
this because it's two of my older
friends once an exec used form executive
at Hasbro as a vehicle booster my little
pony will be another friend of mine is a
fantastic actor on TV so we're going to
create a whole new like three-person
show we're gonna do on YouTube so that's
coming out soon and we will announce
that when we're ready love it all right
whatever having me back thanks for
thanks for coming Juna yeah you were
great Dan Majerle Murrell Dan Admiral
Dan and Dan slab every Monday every
Monday except for this weekend we have
Tuesday isn't Memorial Day on Shinjuku's
plus or doing summer movie report inside
Dan's lap it's all kinds of fun stuff
right stuff yeah heard Lance Henderson I
had mine Hendrix I only wanted coming in
review I was fun I every thing left my
body I couldn't think of anything today
any questions to add interrupted
screaming and you thought I was just
being a jerk and then you're like oh
wait that's Bishop yeah cuz that was fun
to watch
oh yeah tune in there and yet to the
flex pay every Friday 4:00 p.m. we've to
pre-taped as soon as the holiday we're
taping it tomorrow morning but you'll
still be to catch it on YouTube
afterwards and on YouTube screen
Dickey's news 4 p.m. every Friday live
join us and thanks for watching guys
thanks for viewing choice in these three
and please stay tuned next week DC
fights is going to be great next week
it's time for the final championship
battle JC Scott Mints and Mike Carlson
one of them will take on the champ for
the belt it's finally happening I can't
wait no pressure there Dan we'll see you
next time have a good one bye bye